lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
obtener una fórmula para calcular la
longitud de arco de una curva que está
definida en coordenadas polares si esta
curva de aquí es igual a efe de teta
como calculamos la longitud de esta
curva entre dos ángulos theta digamos
como aparece en esta gráfica entre t t
igual a cero radiales itt igual a pi
sobre dos radiales entre cualesquiera
límites para el ángulo theta la manera
como lo vamos a hacer y si en algún
momento dado te sientes inspirada o
inspirado ponle pausa al vídeo e intenta
obtener por tu cuenta la fórmula para la
longitud de arco cuando estamos en
coordenadas polares para esto vamos a
hacer exactamente lo mismo que hicimos
para obtener la fórmula de longitud de
arco en coordenadas rectangulares
empezamos tomando una pequeña sección de
la longitud de arco supongamos que esta
región que estoy marcando aquí es muy
pequeña es infinitesimalmente pequeña
esta es un pedazo una sección
infinitamente pequeña de la longitud de
arco
la cual voy a llamar de ese y obviamente
aquí se ve mucho más grande de lo que
podría considerarse una longitud
infinitesimal al sumar todas estas
longitudes de arco infinitesimales al
integrar las vamos a obtener entonces la
longitud de arco de toda la curva
podemos establecer entonces que la
longitud de arco va a estar dada por la
integral de todos esos infinitamente
pequeños veces la suma infinita de esos
infinitamente pequeños veces nos va a
dar toda la longitud de arco ahora para
expresar de ese en términos de ere y de
teta que es lo que conocemos lo voy a
expresar primero en términos de xy y
luego haremos la transformación para que
quede en términos de r y de teta lo cual
ya hemos hecho antes cuando hemos
convertido en coordenadas rectangulares
a coordenadas polares sabemos entonces
que de ese va a ser igual al
infinitamente pequeño cambio en x
elevado al cuadrado así es que si vamos
de este punto a este punto que es el
cambio en la longitud de arco entonces
esta distancia aquí va a ser el cambio
en x
de equis y luego escribir todo en
términos de diferenciales lo cual quizás
tendríamos que formalizar más desde el
punto de vista matemático aquí
tendríamos que hablar primero de delta
xy luego tomar el límite cuando delta x
tiende a cero y yo lo voy a manejar así
de manera informal pues esto nos permite
de manera intuitiva tener un mejor
entendimiento conceptual de lo que
estamos haciendo así es que este es el
cambio en x cuando vamos de este punto a
este punto mientras que este de aquí es
el cambio en y cuando vamos de este
punto a este punto es de g y como ya
vimos cuando obtuvimos la fórmula para
longitud de arco en coordenadas
rectangulares podemos establecer que de
s es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de de equis elevado al cuadrado más de
ye elevado al cuadrado y esto lo
obtenemos directamente al teoría de
pitágoras más del elevado al cuadrado y
si podemos integrar esto entonces
obtenemos la longitud de arco pero como
podemos expresar esto en términos de ere
y de teta para esto tenemos que recordar
la relación que existe entre las
coordenadas rectangulares xy y las
coordenadas polares y reiter
x sabemos que es igual a r coseno de
teta y esto ya lo vimos cuando empezamos
a movernos entre coordenadas polares y
rectangulares mientras que ye es igual a
r seno de teta y ahora podemos usar esto
para obtener de equis y de equis va a
ser entonces igual a aquí tenemos que
tomar en cuenta que r es una función de
teta
de hecho déjame escribir lo mejor de
esta manera x también lo podemos
escribir como fz que multiplica a jose
no de teta y también por lo mismo que es
igual a efe de teta que multiplica a
seno de teta bien
ahora si podemos obtener de x aplicamos
la regla el producto es la derivada del
primero que es f prima de teta por el
segundo que es coseno beteta más la
derivada del segundo la deriva del
coseno de teta es menos seno de teta así
es que es menos
seno de teta seno de teta por el primero
que es
efe dz éste es de x así es que por
supuesto de teta otra manera de ver esto
es que si divides entre de teta ambas
expresiones como si fueran números
entonces obtendrías que de equis en de
teta es esta derivada que tenemos aquí
así es que ambas expresiones son
equivalentes y ahora vamos a hacer lo
mismo para belle de jour es igual
otra vez aplicando la regla el producto
es la derivada el primero que es f prima
de teta por el segundo por seno de teta
más efe dt está por la deriva de xenón
beteta que es cosa nueva
efe dt está por
coseno dt está ahora para calcular de s
necesitamos primero la suma de de equis
cuadrada más de y cuadrada hagamos eso
x al cuadrado para calcular de x al
cuadrado elevamos primero todo esto al
cuadrado y luego multiplicamos por de
teta al cuadrado entonces va a ser el
cuadro el primero que sería f prima de
teta elevado al cuadrado por coseno
cuadrado de teta menos el doble producto
que tenemos aquí menos 2 veces
efe prima de teta que multiplica a efe
de teta
y eso que multiplica al coseno de teta
seno de teta más el cuadrado del segundo
que sería más
efe de teta al cuadrado por seno
cuadrado de teta y eso por supuesto hay
que multiplicarlo por de teta elevado al
cuadrado
porque te te elevado al cuadrado y ahora
calculemos de ye al cuadrado así que
deje al cuadrado va a ser igual a bien
este término al cuadrado aquí se me
olvidó es de que necesitamos un de teta
así es que es el primer término elevado
al cuadrado que va a ser
efe prima de teta elevada al cuadrado
por seno cuadrado de teta por cero grado
de teta más el doble producto de estos
dos términos más dos veces
efe prima de teta
efe prima de teta por efe dz
efe prima detecta por efe de teta que
multiplica seno de teta y coseno beteta
lo va a poner como arriba que multiplica
a coseno de teta por seno de teta y
luego más el cuadro del segundo que es
efe dt está al cuadrado coseno cuadrado
de teta coseno cuado de teta y eso x de
teta elevado al cuadrado
ahora sumemos estos dos términos vamos a
sumar a ambos lados de las dos
ecuaciones y que lo que obtenemos del
lado izquierdo obtenemos de x elevado al
cuadrado
más del elevado al cuadrado y eso es
igual aquí tenemos un término en común
que es f prima de teta elevado al
cuadrado el cual podemos factorizar
entonces la suma de estos dos términos
nos quedaría vamos a sacar como factor f
prima de teta al cuadrado esto que
tenemos aquí efe prima de teta al
cuadrado que multiplica a
kosen o cuadrado de teta coseno cuadrado
de teta
más seno cuadrado de teta y esto está
muy bien para nosotros porque esta es
una identidad ya conocemos la identidad
pitagórica que vale 1
bien sigamos al siguiente término estos
términos se cancelan pues este término
es el negativo de este de acá así es que
estos dos términos la suma se hace cero
y vamos al tercer término aquí también
notamos que podemos factorizar efe de
teta elevado al cuadrado así es que más
efe de teta
elevado al cuadrado que multiplica a
seno cuadrado de teta
más
coseno
cuadrado de teta y otra vez esta es la
identidad pitagórica que vale 1
finalmente ambos términos están
multiplicando por de teta al cuadrado
así es que todo esto se multiplica por
de teta
beteta al cuadrado podemos pensar aquí
estos de aquí son los coeficientes de
desde tal cuadrado la cual estamos
factor izando y esto ya nos queda más
simple del lado izquierdo nos va a
quedar de x al cuadrado más de g al
cuadrado y del lado derecho tenemos
simplemente f prima de teta al cuadrado
efe prima de teta elevado al cuadrado
más
efe dt está elevado al cuadrado
efe dt está elevado al cuadrado y todo
eso multiplicado por deja de ponerlo con
otro color no ese no es otro color lo va
a poner mejor con este magenta sí
entonces esto que multiplica a de teta
elevado al cuadrado ahora sabemos que de
ese es la raíz cuadrada de eso vamos a
escribir esto así es que d s es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de esto de aquí que lo
mismo que la raíz cuadrada de esto de
acá y aquí lo que podemos hacer con de
teta elevado al cuadrado
tenemos la raíz de algo elevado al
cuadrado nos da simplemente ese algo que
podemos factorizar así es que esto nos
va a quedar la raíz cuadrada de f prima
de tete elevado al cuadrado
efe prima de teta elevado al cuadrado
más
efe dt está elevado al cuadrado y de
teta al cuadrado como decíamos que es un
factor podemos sacarlo de la raíz para
que quede simplemente de teta y esto es
interesante pues si quieres integrar
esto es igual a integrar esto es igual a
integrar esto lo cual finalmente es
igual a esta integral la cual vamos a
evaluar desde el ángulo inicial t t
igual a alfa hasta el ángulo final de
tigua la beta y así ya tenemos espero
que con una comprensión de los conceptos
que hay detrás de esto una fórmula para
calcular la longitud de arco en
coordenadas polares si tenemos que eres
igual a efe de teta encuentras lo que es
f prima de teta la derivada de r con
respecto a teta l base al cuadrado eso
se lo sumas a efe dt elevado al cuadrado
tomar la raíz cuadrada de eso y luego
íntegras con respecto a teta desde alfa
hasta beta tenemos entonces que la
longitud de arco l va a ser igual a esto
que obtuvimos aquí y en los siguientes
vídeos
veremos cómo aplicar esto